avec tout le cérémonial qui s' y ait des
coutumes du perche sont déplacés comme
des reliques
avec mille précautions site ouvrage 15
158 et consulté quasi religieux souvent
c'est l'original des coutumes du perche
qui ont été rédigées en 15/100 56 par
les princes de bourbon et les magistrats
envoyé par le parlement de paris à
l'époque pour consolider les droits des
sujets des français dans cet ouvrage ont
été consignées sur papier vélin avec des
enluminures les textes de loi les
coutumes qui était celle de la province
du perche depuis le moyen-âge c'est
fortuitement que les coutumes du perche
ont été achetés sur un commerce en ligne
5000 euros en 2004 a pris qui avait mis
en émoi le conseil municipal de nogent
le rotrou et pourtant coutumes des pays
comptait bailliage du grand perche et d
autres terres c'est un des premiers
d'ailleurs document juridique écrit en
français puisque dix ans auparavant
françois 1er dans l'es10 de villers
cotterêts avait imposé la rédaction de
tous les textes législatifs en langue
d'usagé pour permettre à tous les
français de comprendre le droit qui leur
était imposé alors que le latin était
réservée seulement à une élite
on a des enluminures sur les lettres
initiales qui sont dans un style
italianisant dans le style maniériste
qui était importée de l'italie dans les
années 15,150 doré à l'or fin
parmi les très nombreux objets du musée
du perche il y a les monnaies liées aux
croisades une retient plus
particulièrement l'attention
c'est une pièce en or à la gloire
d'allah et frappé à jérusalem cette
pièce elle montre que les croisés
fonctionner et gouverner avec des
fonctionnaires des dignitaires musulmans
sous leurs ordres qui
diriger des populations musulmanes et
que dans la réalité des faits il
s'allier avec des seigneurs musulmans
dans des guerres qui parfois les opposer
aussi à d'autres rois crasé donc c'est
toute cette complexité des choses que
qu'on peut retrouver quand on retrace
l'histoire des comptes du perche qui ont
été pris dans des conflits entre
chrétiens et musulmans et qui à la fin
d'ailleurs ont succombé pour les
derniers d'entre eux ce qui a amené
l'extinction à la fin de la dynastie des
roues troupe un enfant du pays
sculpteur émérite camille gâté aura
toute sa place au musée du perche
il se trouve qu'il est en fait le fils
du fondateur d'une tannerie à nos gens
de retrouvent la tannerie ou gâtés puis
villa gâté par la suite et il avait une
âme d'artiste et c'est un artiste très
complet sculpteur mais également
écrivain fondateur d'un journal à
nogent-le-rotrou le musée du perche
témoigne de la vitalité de nogent le
rotrou du moyen âge à la renaissance